[Music]
[Music]
so
so
hello everyone welcome back to gamespot
live i'm richie and we are going to be
playing some more call of duty vanguard
this is the second week of the beta
uh please excuse me i'm a little late i
had to uh had to change the thumbnail
because it's not a completely open beta
not yet it's open beta for those who uh
who are on playstation
if you pre-ordered and you're on pc or
xbox
uh you can play this weekend too but
only if you've pre-ordered so
technically it's not an open beta but
it's cross play you know whatever
i'm done talking let's uh let's jump
right into it let's see here
game only
tada here we go okay so last week i
played on the playstation 5
and uh
exclusive ace gave me the good idea to
try the ps4 version because i can use
the old scuff controller i need every
advantage i can get so let's jump into
it let's see what was added here
um
snd was added that's for sure and i
think they added blitz mode so we can
play that crazy mode i kept talking
about last time
um let's jump right into whatever they
throw at us let's try a quick play here
how we doing chat thanks for hanging in
there good to see you all
neil bread um there are a lot of dates
um
the i've got them all here activision
sent me this a while back um so i'll
read them off to you while we wait
um this september 16th through the 20th
which is this weekend uh it's a
playstation open beta
but from the 18th
through the 20th
it's the open beta entirely for pc and
xbox so there's like there were a total
of like four dates
and they crossed each other a lot so it
was a little hard to keep up but
i'm here to hopefully help you out
yeah the character model looked a little
a little goofy because uh i think it was
the ps4 version of it
but overall i played one match with the
on the ps4
and uh it was okay
like it looked pretty good oh i like
this volk let me know if you guys
i like the volk a lot everyone loves stg
i love the volk i think it's faster
i know um
you guys know me i'm not like mlg over
here but
i need fast shots and i need as many as
i can get that's why i usually like
lmg's too
okay the scuffs working out nicely good
good good
where'd everyone go oh this isn't blitz
pacing that's why i can tell already i
would have been killed long ago
okay i got killed by toy oh you know
what i have stream remote on so you
can't see um
you can't see everyone's real name
some names be straight up offensive
um right in the chat you can play on pc
if you pre-ordered um starting on the
18th even if you didn't pre-order it's
open beta cross play for everybody
uh so some dates are confusing but we're
not there yet
um
let me know how the game audio sounds
you guys i think we had the right mix
going in here like if uh
hopefully my voice isn't too loud or the
game isn't too loud but let me know
no i keep getting shot in the back i
gotta i gotta post up somewhere
yeah you can only play if you
pre-ordered
on pc and xbox if you're on playstation
you can play it's completely open right
now um
ps4 ps4 oh ps4 and ps5
this map is nuts when it's on blitz mode
it's insane or kill confirmed to kill
confirmed blitz mode is like the
craziest way to play this map
what am the hell am i shooting at
over here watch
one bullet left what am i doing
why didn't this guy see me
i have to adjust my left my right stick
excuses excuses i know but
it'll help
hide over here
i think my sensitivity overall needs to
be a little higher
vertical stick that's the right
let's just shoot them both
there we go
that's weird
there's a little dead zone that can be
fixed too you're dead zone uh but i
haven't messed with those settings just
yet all i did was plug in my scuff and i
was like god help me
i also don't have tap to reload on
i should have just stuck with the ps5
version
what are you more excited for uh call of
duty or battlefield i'm very excited for
both i'm really enjoying call of duty
it's just kind of like a reskin of
modern warfare with world war ii theme
but i've never played a battlefield game
so i'm really excited to start that i
said this is going to be my first
battlefield ever this year i mean
clearly uh i
that guy's camping out i was gonna say i
was gonna make a joke about myself and
my skill but that guy's camping out
uh i'm trying to keep up with the chat
let's see here sorry guys
yeah uh the open beta i had
i had to change the thumbnail i keep
dying let me figure this out here let me
get my life
um
but there were so many open and closed
betas there were four weekends i think
total
but bottom line let me explain real
quick this weekend playstation open beta
entirely ps4 ps5 even if you didn't
pre-order if you're on xbox and pc and
you pre-ordered you can play
this weekend
whoa
yeah you can mount love it
i have to change that setting right now
uh for
it was like tap
probably gonna get uh
executed
where is
it equipment behavior hold
tap to reload hold interact
um
okay that sounds right
we'll see
yeah okay that's fine
boy i didn't know
look at what i've become remember
back in the day just pick up the 360
controller and give what they got you
now i'm like oh i need my sensitivity
right otherwise i'm gonna lose i need my
scuff controller i'm gonna lose
i'm an old man
cool counter counter recon
hey get this out of here
wow i'm free firing at this thing and i
can't even take it out goodness gracious
that wasn't even an enemy oh
oh no
hey i hit that guy though
you got a beta you got a beta code and
you can't join oh no where are you guys
getting your codes from
uh um sledgehammer was giving some out
that's the only official source i know
whoa
ah he ran away
uh but i'm sorry it should it should
work if you've got a code yeah that
overrides everything because you can
just join the the beta if you've got a
code on any platform today but
depends where you got your code from man
some guy in a trench coat was like
what are you buying
i keep saying like where is everyone but
i'm hiding out on the side skirts i like
hanging out on the side over here
oh [ __ ] that guy dead right in front of
me
i saw the life leave his eyes
i like going on the roof i don't oh no
damn it i don't go on the roof enough
systems realty says looks mediocre af
yeah i'm getting that a lot uh
people are like mid i'm gonna pass this
year and that's fair you're
obligated to make your own choice
uh but that's why you clicked in you
wanted to make that you wanted to make
that decision you know
oh shoot
oh that's a friendly one
those things are hard to drive the
goliaths they're funny but they don't
shoot you can only run people over and
detonate it like a bomb
so it's kind of funny but i don't think
it works that well
they should add a little gun to it
oh no shot in the back again
oh the cdl codes that's where you guys
are getting from i got two codes from
the cdl stream and it doesn't give me
early access
man i wish i knew what to tell you i
watched the stream
you know when it was going down oh shoot
yo oh my god um
but i couldn't
i don't know you know how those codes
were working i don't know which weekend
it was for
or if it was console specific or
anything like that that guy pissed me
off the one i should have had him oh no
okay that was just me being dumb but i
got him
can't do two things at once clearly
today's the pre-order early access beta
yes for xbox and pc if you're on
playstation it's completely open beta
you don't have to um
you don't have to have pre-ordered
oh man see if i
i could have turned this around i could
have turned this around
yes ps5 early access is
today
all weekend
completely open
you got a playstation just jump in
uh kevin power sorry i missed your your
question this is actually on the
playstation 4. i learned that you can
you know i had it last weekend on the
playstation 5
and i wanted to use my scuff controller
which is only compatible with the ps4
so i just went backwards
let's see here
i didn't use
the stg what's what's unlocked here oh a
new gun
all right i officially unlocked the mp40
let's see here there's so much you can
do to customize your weapons um but i
don't have them
all unlocked yet i'm level 16. i think i
think you can go as high as level 30.
see i was messing around with the
thompson here let me see here
hey look at that
magazine
there we go
just messing around here because things
have changed as far as like ammo type
here we go
fmj rounds subsonic are the ones that
make you go off the radar you can have
ghosts and you can still be um
on the radar i think if you fire your
weapon so you have to have subsonic
rounds it's a little different this year
just a little
all right let's get back into it
quick play
jump into another match
it's not working on ps5 right now nerdy
gimmicks did you get a code from
somewhere
are you just trying to jump in you
shouldn't need a code
what are the chances the hackers will
infest this beta too someone in the chat
earlier said they've already ran into
two
hackers so
oh
heck so yeah i should make some very
cursed loadouts although that thompson
was looking pretty dumb you can really
make a stupid gun in this game and i
love it
5 is the shittiest battlefield i wish i
i haven't played them yet
make the mp40 into an mp5 i need to
unlock way more for that gun um
i used the mp40 a lot
in the alpha and in the first beta but
now i'm using the volk i'll try to
switch it up um
if there's any gun you want me to use
let me know i'm not the best sniper i'll
just say that you guys if you're
returning and you might already know
that
looks like a mod for modern warfare yeah
that's uh
yeah
that's fair
all right um
oh this was good the dp27 was nice
it's like a faster mg42 i think
except for the aim down sights yuck
no that wasn't that bad
check it out hulk smashed hmm
geek
oh i was too busy goofing around okay
the dinner plate yeah
the dinner look at this look at this
mess i don't even know if you can
inspect i'm trying to i don't think you
can
that's
well that's back but look at this
disaster
i put on the site and i was like oh god
i immediately regretted it but
it works okay
slows you down though
this is risky i'm right next to a red
barrel
i'm going to push this down look at that
this is how you get b well you can go up
there if you want but i brought it down
to me
see if i can kill someone with this
thing
this thing is
disgusting
someone's over here at a
[Music]
i guess they're not anymore
usually i like
please excuse me i like to take down
uh spy planes and stuff with the with
the the rockets but the panzer shrek in
this game
uh i miss every time i'm no good at
shooting a free firing rocket launcher
so i'm not gonna do that this round
oh
they're taking baker closing with
charlie
we'll take c then
smoke
that was not a smoke grenade okay i
gotta set that
up someone's here somewhere
is that a friendly stun grenade
whoa
okay let me change that now i want to
put on smoke grenades
smoke grenade excellent
broken for pc that's terrible i'm
hearing that i've been hearing that like
all morning my code isn't working or
it's not working for pc oh [ __ ]
um
so i hope they sorted out that's
annoying it worked for pc when we played
it you know during the private build it
was working fine
he beats a server thing
either way i hope they fix it because
this is annoying although make sure you
have the game pre-ordered you can only
you can only sanchez killed me that's a
fake name um
you can only play on pc and xbox right
now if you pre-order the game if you're
on playstation you can
uh you're good to go it's completely
open on playstation
not able
oh did you guys see that glitch
no
no
i can't ads
fast enough i need to switch to
something else
maybe i can take off that stupid sight
stupid scope
this is ridiculous anyway
no it doesn't affect aim down sight
speed
probably all this does
no
wow it's just a slow ads slower than i
remember i'm gonna switch to um
not the shotgun maybe just the scg for
now oh my god this gun is so that's
hilarious just to look at
right here watch
nope
oh goodness gracious
well well please don't spam max please
don't spam the chat i'm gonna have to
i'm gonna put you on timeout bro
we want you here man i don't want you
spam in the chat
although i think he's sharing great news
i can't tell he's just screaming
something max
closing with baker
i can help out a bee
you see here
i feel like i'm like a bot because i
don't know these maps that well yet
yes okay guppy wow this is
it look stuttering to you guys
on obs it looks a little suddenly let me
know it's uh
good
sparks killed you bro
someone else up there
hmm check it out guys or hulk smash come
on hulk smash there we go
maybe go back to playing the objective
i'll take a let's go get a that's our
spawn
they're taking faker
taking everything
and i got my smoke grenade
securing able baker is lost
oh
no he was behind me it's always behind
me
quests yeah dust off the ps5 bro you're
not playing your ps5 that much
how can this game look uglier than
modern warfare 2019 you know what
well a that's an opinion and that's fine
but b i'm playing on the ps4 um
so i can use my scuff controller i might
have said i know i've said that a bunch
already but
if you're just tuning in
um although i don't think it looks that
different
oh
no i'm gonna switch to let's try another
smg
i haven't used the thompson all morning
okay scan a f repair on pc and it will
work says snap that's what max was
saying okay
you guys are on pc having troubles
remember you have to pre-order it on pc
if you want to play
going to be going to be
oh they already finished wow i jumped
stupid controller oh snap
i was surrounded
so chilled what's up you're gonna flip
the spawn only keep two yeah were we i
wasn't trying to trip cap
uh we're good now and we got the lead so
i'm gonna just stay on defense until
they try to take
the rest
thompson can i make it this far
there we go
they're taking baker
he's out here
wow so much for destructible cover now i
just suck
oh you know what i'm going to turn down
butcher also that was the setting that's
just he talks too much
dialogue volume there we go
push it down to like
70. that'll do because butcher talks way
too much
someone who's right here where they go
did you get that
all right let's go back we gotta keep
two so i'm gonna go try to i'll probably
go for a
might get sniped though
look hulk smash
oh
going for a going for a
oh man i don't have a
that's a stunner not a smoke grenade let
me change that real quick
oh yeah
there we go
all right i'm not gonna
they have b i'm not gonna mess with that
but they're on c i will mess with that
charlie is overrun well i'm at b let me
just go to b
i'm like
i'm saying my play-by-play out loud i
don't know how helpful it is but
there we go
oh hit armor dang it
dang it dang it
securing charlie
okay
thank you guys for tuning in in a few
minutes in a few seconds here when this
match is over
i want to explain the
beta dates and how you can play today um
you might not be able to but you want to
be sure everyone gets in
oh look at me getting lifted up
that's the gun of choice man the stg
everyone loves that gun it's good too
it's really steady but um i'm just
trying to mix it up man
there we go
losing objective faker
we're losing baker again oh my god
goodness gracious
right okay it's on pc it looks like scan
repair
what's it called
do i have a streamer account uh this is
no this is my main account i have
streamer mode on so that we don't see
some offensive ass names
but um
this is my actual account
i'm glad i can pay you back
are they catching up no way let me uh
just clean things up here oh there's a
guy over there
okay
great quick dub let me break down
let me break down what's going on okay
so today
from
the 16th through the 20th
if you're playing on playstation it's
completely open beta you don't have to
pre-order
this weekend if you're on playstation
you don't need a code
but this weekend if you are
on xbox and pc you either need a code to
get in
or
you need to have pre-ordered the game it
is an early access beta for xbox and pc
uh i hope that helps
uh some codes i hear aren't working and
try to say what's up with see what's up
with the chat i want to keep up with you
guys appreciate you being here
um
but it is a live baited now yes
neil for pc players it looks like it's
starting to work
uh hexa yes my tommy gun was modded
terribly i was just trying to
goof around and see what's up
um i wish i could help every technical
question here
but i'll do what i can i hope i hope um
i hope that helped because it's not
completely open it's not a completely
open beta yet
uh the game does have dismemberment you
can get your head blown off and get your
legs blown off let me check my settings
and see if that is enabled
i think it is
interface
where is it
this is cool you can turn this off
because during the alpha the crosshair
was jumping up and down i was like no
thank you no thank you
where the hell is it graphics
it should be here right
i swear i might have skipped it but i
swear dismemberment was uh was a thing
and you can turn it off
oh well but it is a thing if someone's
using the right ammo type you can they
can blow your head off and i've seen it
and i've done it
matt says i bought cod last year is this
worth another 60 bucks right now is the
time for you to make that decision my
friend if you're on playstation it is an
open beta
and you can see for yourself whether or
not you like it it is a lot it is pretty
similar to modern warfare 2019 there are
the same systems like
uh mounting the same sliding
uh the same gunsmith as you saw just now
uh but the maps are a little different
the guns are a little different
i think you should
try it out for yourself
because i don't know i can't tell you if
it's worth 60 bucks not i can't
personally tell you i'm you know i
pre-ordered um because i'm excited for
it let me back up here hold on i want to
try blitz mode there's no blitz mode
jeez i guess not
search and destroy man maybe it's later
this weekend this always happens to me
words says i can't believe they delayed
battlefield 2040 for this yeah
we want it we want a good game
let them uh you know
let them do their thing they want to
make sure they come correct although i
can't wait for the battlefield uh
beta testing
can you test the weapon mods before each
match like in world war ii no i wish
like remember the uh you remember
obviously but
uh for those of you who don't in world
war two you can have like you know the
little um
test testing firing range they even had
that in cod mobile
look blitz pacing what 10 versus 10
that's not blitz
i think it can it can go up to 24v24
though
what are you on about yeah okay they
didn't yeah battlefield didn't delay
their game
for this they just need more time it
just happened to fall it happened to
push it back a week after
call of duty's gonna be announced or
call of duty's date
um
i'm gonna try the volk again i like that
gun i wish i could unlock it
the volk here we go this is my class
kanye west in the chat i can't install
the game um what platform are you on man
that might um well i died right away um
remember on playstation it's open beta
but if you're on xbox unless you have a
code you can't get in
or unless you pre-ordered the game
oh
you there oh my god it's lagging bro
black and i'm lagging
i'm gonna use that whenever i just die
like oh i slag so much lag in this game
just kidding
clear as day
this guy
was pre-aiming good stuff
okay this is look at all these tags this
gives me uh this freaks me out a little
bit
just pick up the tags that's how we win
okay that was someone else killed them
not me
oh i just jumped right into that one
oh no
look at my head got blown off see my
brains let's watch that again in an
instant replay
that's too far oh well he blew my head
off
kanye west says the soulja boy console
yeah that is not this is uh
this beta is not available on the soulja
boy console none of them i think there's
like three soulja boy consoles god i'm
just trying to pick up tags
what platform are you on i am currently
on um
playstation 4.
last weekend i was on playstation 5
but you can play with your scuff
controller so i just switched to the ps4
all right let's let's try to get some
kills i'm going to be tactful about this
look at that see
oh my god
oh
i'm out of bullets i'm dead i'm toast
oh thermite
he died someone else killed him huh yeah
he's dead
great and he picked up the tag
let's see let's see
that guy's dead
excellent oh that was a really loud
ricochet oh no
yes
and oh i almost fell off the damn
building
got you friend oh no
i haven't tried blind firing yet i'm too
scared to do that i think i've done it
like once up too far away too far away
oh and i got killed anyway dang it
man this game is called a booty i'm not
a fan oh i'm sorry words i mean thanks
for checking out the video anyway i
appreciate you being here and whatever
you know hanging out talking some [ __ ]
but
it's not for everybody a lot of people
are just like you know they hear oh
a lot of people are they hear world war
two and they're like no i'm not into it
uh but this is like
uh
uh aaron sampson from gamespot you know
uh my colleague he said uh this is like
a
a reskin of modern warfare 2019
and
i pretty i pretty much agree it's it's
pretty great because i loved modern
warfare 2019 though
look that's rolling deep
but yeah obviously you're entitled to
your opinion and i'm getting killed
wise guy says i'm going to stick with
cold war
i play co i play cold war for like
zombies i really like zombies
quest says i'm totally into world war ii
stuff all right my man
you should try this out i hope you're
able to play the beta sometime this
weekend i hope you have a code or
you're on playstation
whoa
collect tags click the tags okay good
i'm better at collecting the tags than i
am shooting and killing people good lord
uh can i use the
customize the thompson
into the thompson m1a1 uh technically
i'm i'm pretty sure you know what i'm
not gonna pretend like i know what i'm
saying
i'm not i think it comes that way let's
see in the default class like that's
what they call it
oh the m1 and no i'm not sure if you can
i wish i knew because i'm not you know
uh savvy
with that stuff this is my thompson it
looks like crap but
i love it uh but i wish i could answer
that on a technical level i don't think
so
i mean i i don't know i'll put it that
way whoa
this is blitz pacing y'all blitz pacing
how many people are in this lobby look
at this
actually no it's only 10 v10
okay last time when we did it it was
like
i think 24 v24 it was a nightmare
on this map
so much recoil got him
whoa
come on toy again
that fake name
jumping slugs what's up he says what
guns are available let me just break it
down real quick here are the basic ones
that you can the pre selected classes
scg mp4 uh mp40 m1 the volk volkstrom
revolving shotgun
this four round burst uh
itra the three line rifle which i forget
it goes by different name mg42 thompson
the bar and there's more but um
i've been using the volk a lot it's fun
and it's fast and it's an ar
oh
[Music]
wow call of duty says uh
i'm not even yeah call of duty but
spelled like dookie
hmm
i'm scared to go up in the middle again
that's such a hot zone
just gonna hang out here with my boys
oh two of them two of them help
this game look slick i mean appreciate
it i'm not this is not the best gameplay
but
that has long since been established
that as much as i love call of duty and
for despite how long i've played i'm not
the best player that's okay i mean you
guys are here to just check it out
for the graphics i don't think you're
here for some high kill gameplay but if
you are you're in the wrong place let's
see
goodness also this is blitz pacing i'm
gonna keep using that as my crutch
excuse uh there's a thousand people in
here and i keep dying
i like blitz pacing when it comes to
playing team deathmatch collecting the
tags is a whole different journey
there they go
i'll take these tags though
what i mounted oh no there's like three
people here oh let me try another gun
because that'll help me right
we're about to lose anyway
okay the mp40 classic
pick up the tags we can turn this around
sweet project says the sound is [ __ ] or
sounds [ __ ]
it's hardcore in the beta no there's
there's um
there that's a good question but no it's
not it's regular
well that's a good question because
well bottom line no but they have combat
pacing where it's like
6v6
uh i think like assault is 10v10 and
blitz is like 20 something people but
look at this there's no
backup here
this is these are our options for
the first day of the beta just team
deathmatch
normally there'd be a tab right here
that's like hardcore something like that
but no or in the filter which and the
filter as you can see is locked
so nothing like that yet
y'all talking about ghosts of tsushima i
got to get on that game
i got to get on so many games all i do
is all i do is play call of duty no
skinny
yesterday i played um
the new cruising game that's on the
switch i had so much fun i love that
game
it was so funny like you can unlock
instead of a race car you can unlock a
dinosaur or a ufo
i was laughing so hard
this is world war ii looks the same
james wright yeah uh it's it's the same
engine as modern warfare if that means
anything
to you i mean uh i don't know what
you're comparing it to
but it looks
i would say yeah it's mostly a mix of oh
this is a good map it's mostly a mix of
world war ii from 2017 and
modern warfare
shark tank says i hate this game so much
we know it that's fine i'm i'm glad
you're here
i hope you're not here to just you know
say that all the whole chat but if
you're here
you might have some interest i don't
know either way bottom line thanks for
being here
uh and you are definitely entitled to
that opinion oh
come on sanchez
sanchez
i think this bigger map i'm gonna try
this maybe the mg42 this time yeah my
thompson does look like a machine pistol
it looks silly look at this
because it shows that the ammo i have an
ammo drum but it's a thin ammo drum and
i took the butt off
and i'm about to die
there we go anyway yeah it looks funny
i have that
uh
what's it called that mode on where you
can tell where people are looking at you
i hate that i should turn that off
i'm being watched
i'm just gonna blind fire
yeah
i'm out of here i hate this building
i gotta pre-aim like a mother with this
wait someone behind me
oh
i can mount but i can barely see
that angle that angle
where'd he go
i'm literally peeking my head like like
this i don't know
oh no i got
smoked
okay okay
wow wow okay good wow and as in that's
all my fault but
no
oh
right in his ankles oh
man
can't wait for the full release world
war ii should be revisited more often
like before that is a hot take but
i'm having fun with this game
i just say that because a lot of people
just despise world war ii games because
they they did him for like 10 years you
know
oh
okay maybe i'm gonna post up somewhere
oh we lost never mind
hello is there a zombies mode or not uh
gaming life there will be a zombies mode
with the full release but there isn't
for
the beta
and the good news is well in my opinion
that treyarch will be developing the
zombies
not sledgehammer
oh my god
stupid coffee
went down the wrong pipe terrible
i got coffee all over my flavor town
shirt
that's okay
[Music]
looks better than 17 17 oh
yeah world war ii from 2017
that's good i'm glad it looks better
should technically it should but i'm
playing on the playstation 4
um last weekend i played on playstation
5.
and uh
[Music]
it ran smooth but i just like my scuff
controller and it only works for
playstation um for
billy madden no no this is ps4
version aaron sampson mg life yeah
aaron do you see me did you see me choke
on my coffee like
30 seconds ago
my god
maybe i should i can't do two things at
once
should i use what should i use
what are the default classes
i really like the volk the burst rifle
i'll try it out it's okay
domination let's go
another classic showdown i can't wait
oh cool oh friendly friendly
all right come on burst rifle
losing objective
what oh nevermind
they can have baker i'm going for c baby
no to my right
oh no to my left damn
no um
meek gamer i can't change the fov yet
but in the full release
that will be an option
i was hoping they'd have it let me
double check i was hoping they'd have it
in the second um beta here but they
don't
controller graphics i'd be interface
maybe
you can have your oh you can have your
packet loss show up nah no fov yet
whoa
we're losing a i'm here rambling
oh no
oh great the panzer shrek no thanks
i love the print the panzer shrek but um
that guy was going gung-ho
um
but i can't lock onto rockets and i'm
i'm pretty bad at using it when it comes
to anti-air
in this beta
whoa
wow i was trying to cut him off but i
went around the whole damn map no
all for nothing
where'd he go
whatever
probably gonna get executed just
standing here but at least you guys will
be able to see that
executions are back
yeah i'm not using this i'm sorry i
can't i'm no good at
three round four round burst guns
i need to spray and pray because uh i'm
not you know i'm
spy
plane i have a counter spy plane in it
oh oh oh lag spike
all right let's actually play the
objective here let's see if i can get to
b or maybe back to a
they're taking charlie
what the [ __ ]
leave it alone
the guy was picking on me with the
thompson from so far away are there any
vehicles you can use no
currently no not on this not on these
maps
nice someone threw a smoke grenade oh
that guy's on fire what the hell just
happened here
this might be the wrong type of thinking
but i'll try it anyway i think
oh it's while i'm aiming down sights let
me back up this is the corner i need a
better corner oh my god
black spike
mike spike
what
oh j-rock thanks for updating um i
haven't checked twitter since i've been
streaming but sledgehammer says they uh
that they're looking into the series x
graphical issues good
stuff is overrun
finally oh i was like finally i killed
someone and i get killed let me try one
more thing this is a
um
with the here we go the the details
with low zoom let me turn that up a
little bit actually with all of them let
me turn turn it up just a little bit
just a little
uh
that's that's okay i think
man it's so nice to customize on this
level nowadays
uh even though i still really stink at
this game but
um
i have a fighting chance
no i don't look my leg got blown off
hey joshua welcome um i'm playing
currently on the ps4
just so that i can use my scuff
controller
finally i killed someone good lord i
should be playing the objective not just
going for kills but
i'm trying to get to the objective here
wait someone's on the hill
oh no i'm too distracted
he was like sonic the hedgehog i think
he was using cheats oh wow
um
yeah i hope people aren't i mean
i hate talking about that but it's true
like
teachers are gonna cheat forever yo get
me on this boat
wilcox these are all fake names i have
streamer version
does this version of cod have skill
based matchmaking i'm sure it does
they're never gonna
it's always it's always been there but
you know
the last few years it's been pretty
strict and i don't think that'll change
for a while because it's such a such a
big game they want i think their their
discussion about that was they want to
make it approachable for everyone so oh
my god there we go so um they have a
high skill set for skill-based
matchmaking did we get b at least we got
b that's being taken away from us
77 venture wow gameplay really
aggressive uh
i mean aggressive doesn't equal good i
mean sure
i like to push but then i get i get
killed a lot as you guys can see on the
stream
um
this probably isn't the best gun also
for
this map this mode oh
yeah maybe i should be less aggressive
let me try let me try hanging out with a
with a longer range weapon
like an ar
just hanging out
after i kill this guy
smoke grenade oh
no get away
no
surrounded surrounded
you're a bot yeah i've heard that before
i don't
the way i play is so unlike
streamers and pros that you're used to
you know that do like the all this slide
i can't even freaking do it um
i'm a very old-school
geezer stuck in my ways call of duty
player um
i did turn off motion blur though that's
a thing
so yeah
where you at faze sign me up
yeah uh
i'm not i wouldn't say i'm bought so
much as old man
there you go
i've just played i played since uh cod 4
and like i really have not adapted or
updated my ways and then it gets me
killed why don't you play on playstation
5 um i can i did last weekend if you
want to check that video out it's a lot
like this where i just die a lot but
um i'm on playstation 4 because i want
to use the scuff controller
um
it's nice uh it has the back pedal so i
can
run with uh
oh it doesn't help me clearly but it's
more comfortable on my hand
this guy was right behind me i just
missed them entirely
let's see here
mg
i'm gonna make a new class when this
game is over because i these are these
guns are are good well i mean i'm not
good these guns are good
but i think we should switch it up
see what's made see what's available i'm
level i think 16 now
some guns should have been unlocked
come on no one come at me from the left
please
just coming here dropping bombs words
not words you've been in here for a
while
oh you're already talking about it from
seeing the recent gameplay of
battlefield 20 42 it looks like they're
going back to bf4 style i wish i could
comment on that air if aaron sampson is
still in the chat
he'll go off
but oh no
um
but i don't know anything about
battlefield which is oh [ __ ] i'm
surrounded one behind me i saw him
where was he oh no
there was one behind me but i went for
the guy in front of me whatever
no camp mate
maybe i should camp
you know what for the sake
i don't know i'm just so i just i really
don't want
oh my god is this blitz mode no this is
not at all this is c on the top right
tactical 6v6
and i got
yo
can i breathe
that should be a stream huh how many
times does richie just naturally get
killed in a game of call of duty
great
thanks to me now i'm kidding
there you go aaron sampson is still in
the chat
kingdom pumpkin says i really hope
there's a button to turn off cross play
yeah if it's like
on warfare or war zone there would be i
you know i think even cold war had that
so yeah i'm hoping that's an option too
uh because as you can see i could use
all the help
gamer in the chat wow you just got the
name gamer absolute trash
thanks brother thanks for being here
oh yeah let's make a new class back up
here
um these are the ones i mostly use i
don't use a shotgun i i tried it
and i had bad luck with it i mean as
surprise surprise
here
so let's change this up
ah
there is a pre-made class for the bar so
i can use it but
i haven't unlocked it yet level 18
the nz41
hmm
this is what i want i want the bulk but
it's the last gun
unlocked at level 30 i think you can go
up to level 30 um i'm not there yet
the sten
that one
it's kind of slow uh it kind of chugs i
don't know if i should use that
do you think zombies is going to be
added not in the uh not in the beta i
don't think they'll probably have their
own event
where it might be actually no it's not
true i have no idea what's gonna happen
with zombies
the bren is here oh yeah the mohawk gun
the m1 that has i used it for a little
it has some serious kick
you guys don't want to see me sniping
well i guess that there aren't that many
you know they're going to add so many
guns later in the year
um this is like just the beginning
maybe i should make an mp40 class
everyone loves the mp40
flash hider
hmm
okay
that goofy site
scope i like this one
remove the stock
initial accurate no initial that's
that's very specific i don't know if i
like any of these so i'm gonna i'm not
gonna do it let me see here
yeah don't affect my recoil i i
suck
uh
at aiming like i love to spray and i get
lucky a lot but i don't know about that
man
there we go recoil recovery there we go
that's what i'm talking about
okay mp40 class
um here are the secondaries
good luck on the beta thanks kingdom
pumpkin thanks for being here if you're
taking off it's good to see you
um you think this would look better on
the ps5
no blue
i mean i have i have it but i i wanted
to play with the scuff controller if you
go back to last week's stream you'll see
me playing playstation 5.
i unlocked the rat
combat knife what level
level 22 i've seen some fun gameplay
with that already
i don't think i'll get to level 22 today
okay perks let's see what i should pick
what's the difference between ghost
and low profile
immune to the effects of piercing vision
oh
that's kind of cool but it's a little
specific i want something let's see here
yeah i'll stick with ghost what's
survival training
oh yeah okay
high alert no that's what i don't like
that freaks me out it works but i'm like
i'm already freaked out enough as it is
uh
radar cool i love i love me intel so i
might put radar on
i like tracker too
but i don't have it unlocked
double time definitely whatever it is i
always i'll take double time anytime
okay
maybe a smoke grenade and i'm ready
richie b's custom class
okay let's play
checking while at the dentist oh my
goodness
good luck hope you get no cavities
i hope you don't have any cavities
uh smith i would say the attachments are
are more like
2019's modern warfare
um
you know in cold war each attachment is
like better better better and then in
modern warfare it's like
better but more downsides
so mixing and matching is key i think
will there still be a campaign yes
know this is uh
call of duty vanguard
the beta is not out for everyone that's
a good question i haven't talked about
it in a while if you're on playstation
go for it you don't need a code you
don't need
uh to pre-order just go it's ready
playstation players open beta for xbox
and pc
you either need a code
or you need to have pre-ordered the game
and then we can all cross-play together
but you don't have a code
in a pre-order
forget about it
until next weekend or actually until
until the 18th on the 18th whoa whoa
whoa
on the 18th it becomes open beta for all
from the 18th to the 20th remember that
if you want to play
oh now look at this
oh what's
even know what to call that that's
artifacting
uh
jump on the roof here
wow that guy just cleaned up
thanks man
i gotta pre-aim more pre-aim pre-fire
more oh yes it's not kill confirmed
i'm not confirming [ __ ]
as i bust through that wall
no
hort fake name hort
any bugs i've encountered so far i mean
a little just uh it's mostly like server
issues
and on playstation there's minor
graphical issues everything
generally runs smooth
well they killed my friend
show yourself
oh
no
god
killed him with his own grenade that
never happens to me
yeah
mp40 is where it's at baby
oh no no no it's not it's not happening
it's not happening
ah rats
chris l no i'm not british
what happened to the game look what's
happening
oh well you guys asked if any bugs were
happening
look at me oh
all right oh
looks like a a big time server issue
and uh
not not to flex but i recently upgraded
my internet so i don't think
it's a oh
oh my god
oh are we done
are we done here no look at look at my
running cycle i'm going so fast this is
broken
i'm lowered
oh my god
oh
i got who shot me in from where what was
that okay i think we're back i think
we're back
oh my god
shot that guy right in the butt
oh glad that's over
i thought the game was just going to end
scaring me teammate
whoa
what the
he shooting me through this
through this i don't know i don't know
about that
maybe he has special fmj rounds maybe
fmj rounds actually work as advertised
in this game
going around
by the way if i am really if i am too
loud let me know because i don't i want
the the audio to be balanced of course
got my leg blown off
are you richie's with a sonic profile
pic
uh
where am i that's why that's weird
i think i used to be
whoa
whoa
whoa whoa
yeah
oh oh my god
double kill yeah for once
going up
i remember when i choked on my coffee
this is a good corner for me every time
i hit up this corner i get a double kill
oh oh baby a triple
that yeah god's punished me for saying
that out loud
but now i'm level 17.
and we're taking the lead
is that someone
with thought oh it's a friendly god
i have no whoa
yeah i'm gonna jump off the building
i lived
oh wow that's words that's good you are
good with words that's funny i turned it
into cough coffee because i was choking
on my coffee
god
wow my kd wasn't
absolute [ __ ] like i thought look at
that level 18
i finally got the spy plane
oh because there's intel and then
there's spy plane right right right
mp40 is where it's at friends
i had a good match with that let me
back up and see what i unlocked
what the
i didn't do that
chris l good job oh thanks man
always always love a dub on the stream
um
see here
the silencer
hmm
recoil control is nice let's see
but damage range is also important
i'll try it out this also doesn't keep
you off the midi map you need subsonic
ammunition to do that i'll show you
never mind i don't have ammunition
unlocked for this yet
recoil aim down sight speed goes down
i'll stick with the stippled rip tape
thank you very much
look at this
that's like not even
we're dropping historically accurate out
the window we did long ago that's okay
but it looks like i don't even know uh
someone someone in the chat tell me what
butt of the gun that looks like that
looks like an
i'm not even gonna guess i'm gonna
yeah but look at all these
no stock
let's see here
hip fire hip fire i don't think i need
movement speed
but it takes away my recoil initially so
i'm not gonna oh yeah last time i was
like no i'm not gonna do it so i'm still
gonna do it
let's move on i unlocked
tactician
that's cool um
now keep double time okay let's get back
to the match
what oh yeah
i'm good i think
what else did i unlock here
oh look ammo type 4
there you go this is what keeps you off
the radar look at that no mini mapping
no enemy skulls
and it reduces firing visibility to
enemies okay i'll put that on
yeah
okay let's get back to it
i'm i hate this little orange triangle
just go away there we go go away
what's up chat are you guys playing
oh if you're playing on playstation it's
open beta if you're on xbox you need a
code or you need to pre-order same for
pc
um there are no new guns from last
weekend in the beta the same guns
they'll probably add more later in the
year
all right
let's get into it oh look eagles nest
perfect
i don't think we've played this yet on
the stream
i like this map
the sound of this game is horrible
big and beastly
says that hmm
let's go with mp40 again i had a good
match last time
i think this sounds okay personally it's
kind of low though
oh
oh lag lagville
oh my god i'm scooting across the floor
oh my god
yeah okay oh
what the oh
you guys like my hacks oh my god
oh my god
did i get that second guy or nah
whoa
dude's falling from the ceiling
check this out
yeah
all right i won't hang out there for
very long but you can break some walls
and stuff and oh my god this lag
oh no this is pretty rough
i'm gonna blame the lag for that one
oh my god
oh my gosh this is really disorienting
oh
they finally got me
is this on mobile that's funny unless
you're being serious no it's not mobile
oh the lag
or what i should do
i don't think there's anything you can
do
except get out of this game but it's
pretty funny
oh no
hey bad guy
[Music]
[Laughter]
there's the guy who did it
oh
god
[Laughter]
but
i stopped firing what the hell's wrong
with this
yeah i'm definitely staying in this
lobby though
okay
oh my gosh
get me out of this corner
the game won
the game won't allow it
maybe this is the only way i'll do
better is just if
crappy lobbies like this
oh my okay i stopped moving what killed
me
i gotta see this
have this guy i don't know we're all
going through it
oh my
god
i hope you guys are at least
entertained because this is hilarious
what what what
[Laughter]
i'm still alive
oh
my goodness
hey someone's up here maybe okay i think
it's
all right i think i think we're ah
i think we're
finally getting back on track
i don't know i don't know
okay come on
hey i got a spy plane
can't even call it in there we go
oh my gosh
[Laughter]
execute
nope
no execute oh
my god
yeah it's either the beta servers or my
network that's making it lag
don't know i would say oh my god
oh
oh okay yep
i went through purgatory just now oh my
god is my mic mike's never where he
needs to be
can you hear me okay great
what all right
how are we how is it 80 to
70
when
in these conditions
a second ago it was 50 to 50 and now
it's like 80.
we're still getting kills nothing is
stopping us folks
oh
okay all right
yeah playstation 4 maybe you should
switch to nah it's not a it's not a
console thing i was thinking of
switching to the playstation 5 version
but uh it wouldn't be this funny that's
for sure
oh my god
okay
oh
oh
oh look at us whoa
i just want to get out of that room okay
i was like oh i love this map and i can
barely even
see it
uh or show it to you guys because of all
this
oh
oh well you know what yeah put me out of
my misery that was funny for a little
bit but oh my god get off that walmart
wi-fi that's funny i prefer gas station
wi-fi so please be
nice look at that hey wow
1kd
that's that's the official keeping my
head above water kd
no let me back out and start over
well it looks like it's doing that for
me
that's a good question gaming life i
don't know how to uh you usually in this
room i have a good connection
i have no problem the next room over is
the the wi-fi router and modem it's
usually not a problem to play online
games
so i i'm it might just be
on their end hopefully i mean i don't
want to play on i mean i'm also
streaming uh and the stream is holding
up well so that's a good sign let me
back out all the way
yeah let's let's do all this get all
this out of the way
and uh see if that helps
oh my god yeah
that's funny yeah remix miami says uh
the bullet can't touch you because
you're caught in the matrix yeah that's
exactly look at that they admit it
they failed i'm just kidding all right
let me back up i want to back up all the
way
maybe i should uh
hmm
okay i think it i think it did its
things just try again
did i unlock anything look at that i
somehow even unlocked stuff for my my
gun
fmj rounds let's do it
man i wanted to show you guys eagle's
nest too
activision employees in the chat they're
like no no it is your connection it is
not the game's responsibility
you know what um
there's a way in the interface to show
like packet loss and stuff like that
so let's see
connection meter oh server latency
packet loss
system clock
let's go let's put me on blast
see on the top left
i'll make it big for y'all to see
excellent
all right
let's see
uh it's the same on zombies cold war
i've seen people
like get on high rounds of zombies
lately still
or like get the ray gun on a high level
and then the game just crashes but it's
on pc though that's that's so
unfortunate
all right
top left
i actually don't know what's good so let
me know if seventy
what's good what's normal
is it really
gas station wi-fi let me know i don't
even know if that means if that directly
affects my wifi
but this game is already running much
smoother thank goodness
no the second i turn around
yeah aaron betas b betas play a better
game hey man you clicked into this video
and you knew exactly what you were
getting into
i see what you're saying if if that's a
a wi-fi related
dis
okay that guy wanted no smoke oh god
can i just get a please
maybe i should go for b
those guys love a and they're defending
a to the max
man
good he came back
whoa
man come on i thought i had that guy
wait a few months and buy this game
don't get it on release see how it
treats the platforms first or see how it
performs on release first yeah
you can do that
uh this is good though the beta is all
is such a good test for all of this
stuff i just you know this is uh this is
how they get feedback this is how they
fix issues so i'm down for just beta
testing like this
um
adam yeah there are gonna be zombies
yeah aaron sampson responded in the chat
they're made by treyarch this year great
news
okay smoke grenade everyone leave me
alone
charlie is overrun
yeah finally
securing baker
come on there we go
that didn't help
this guy's trying it too
jump out the window
quit taking baker
come on i had shots on that guy
how are you playing on pc oh
i'm not but if you're wondering about
the latency up top on the top left and
the packet loss they added that to
console it's in the settings
chat how do you fix the auto fire on
automatic weapons what do you mean man
bad guys
i'm helping no i'm not they already did
it
oh yeah
oh yeah they're really talkative when
especially when you get a comeback kill
double kill
no he's to my right dang it dang it dang
it
i want a beta code for pc i want to play
sorry gaming life i wish i had them to
give away
is vanguard campaign free for pc i don't
think i don't think so it's going to be
a complete package you know where they
charge
one price for everything
like every year whoa
got him
no
moving around moving and sound
like cold war this howard thinks it
sounds like cold war
interesting interesting
i think that's what he's saying
okay let's go back okay we don't need a
triple cap i'm not gonna get a but i'm
gonna shoot that guy that's for sure
wasting bullets
yeah
my friend was here to save me no don't
get a don't get a
oh well we can get a i guess and catch
up because we are not in the lead at the
moment
this is world war ii but everyone in the
battle in the battlefield is rambo
yeah this is pretty nuts
that's a fun way to put it we're all
just rambo
john rambo
that guy killed me before
forget and i can't i can't do anything
about it apparently
going around bring it around town
that's still there
eat this
whoa
double kill i got him
i gotta pre-aim i got i gotta pre-aim
way more
wait someone's there
okay that was just lucky
for me
yeah wallbang
going for c why not
smoke out
dang it
uh does this cod have the flags and the
calling cards uh the calling cards
aren't
unlocked right now like we have them but
they're default ones
so i can't tell you if you know i can't
give you that answer i don't know
hopefully i mean i think they do every
year right
going back for c
hey
you again
i think he blew my head off
but the camera didn't show it watch
let's see
that didn't help either damn
i'm playing on playstation 4. it is
available
on playstation 4 and playstation 5.
uh if you want to see what it looks like
on playstation 5 we streamed this last
weekend on playstation 5.
so check it out
leave me alone
yoink
i i i'm playing on playstation 4 because
i can use my scuff controller
they haven't made a scuff for ps5 yet
have they
the first scuff i ever bought i was like
wow i finally made the jump to a scuff
i feel like a pro and uh
only got to use it for a year because
the playstation 5 came out
you killed my friend
haha
i'm dead
oh he blew my leg off
okay i'm off to play cold war have a
great time playing thanks for being here
uh appreciate it
oh noah jay is having trouble loading in
you missed it if you just joined us you
missed a really laggy round last match
it was hilarious so i'm sure there were
server issues
any new maps or guns out yet no new guns
from what i can tell but they did trevor
they did add
eagle's nest which was i think
i don't know if it was in the beta last
weekend
i think it might have showed up in the
beta late last weekend
uh but if not it's a new map
okay it's 11 30. i want to play one more
match and then we'll call it there
let's see here
mp40 has been treating me nicely i had a
really rough start and uh got my ass
handed to me a lot
look at this ugly scope
oh my god
no thanks
hmm
there are so many different
eight millimeter oh
reload quickness i'll give this a shot
i think it's just a quick mag
okay
trevor says how is it oh if you're
talking about the new map uh i like it
um
eagle's nest is like a mountaintop map
it looks really nice it's during the
daytime but it mostly takes place inside
uh i would say it's a small or more like
a medium-sized map
that i really enjoyed
mp40 on this map
more domination all right whatever
oh no look at look at the latency up top
charlie
now does that mean
my internet's goofy or
servers i don't know
oh my god it's happening again no
i'm not back out of this game i don't
want the last game to be a lag fest
oh my god it's happening again
oh
not this again yeah
i'm not that i'm gonna back out this is
not cool
not for the last match
take the l
okay good i didn't
choke on my coffee like i did
an hour ago
let me back up again
um
okay no update that's good
let's try this
what do you think about the game so far
especially for all the crazy
customizations going on on a world war
ii weapon
i like that a lot of people i i'm
enjoying the beta and the game so far
uh but yeah it's not not at all
historically accurate and i think it's
for
you know they have that for players in
mind you can customize the hell out of
your gun
and it's really goofy um so i like it
for the sake of gameplay i think it's
goofy
worth buying or not i don't know man
right now we're in the beta now it's a
good time to check it out
by the way if you're on playstation
open beta go for it if you're on xbox or
pc
you need to pre-order the game but
if you pre-order the game you can play
um
starting however starting september 18th
even if you didn't pre-order it's open
beta across all platforms september 18th
that's coming up
are you able to change your character
yet no i'm not they they change it every
time to one of the main characters and
there's no
no way to pick it up or no way to change
it
latency above 100 ms is not considered
good yeah i figured it was turning red
it was like 400 for a second it kept
spiking
it's terrible
oh no i hope they didn't put me back in
the same match
no i don't think so this is 6v6
maybe maybe i'll try the mg one more
time
oh this is not looking good
look at look at look at the latency i
think am i seriously back in the same
match
man
maybe the servers are just getting hit
really hard i should have quit
i can't even kick open this door wait is
that a door to kick open yeah it is
i'm in ghost town
i'm floating time has stopped
i try to change my weapon
this is what happened
yeah okay good
kick me out
good good good
let's
let's not do that oh
okay
last time this happened i think it
helped so let's let's let it do its
thing
try one more time
servers are down says jesse in the chat
you know what we might have to end it
here
the stream was uh you know for like 90
minutes like normal so
if this doesn't work i might just call
it
but this is an open beta for playstation
players so that's good news for you you
don't need a pre-order but if you have
it on xbox or pc
um you need a pre-order or have a code
then you can play although no one can
play right now i guess because it's
goofing up
uh but this is going on for the entire
weekend so i'm sure they will
fix things
and give this like another
whatever 30 seconds say what's up to you
guys in chat
try sniper if you can yeah matrix that
was funny i was definitely the maid i
felt like neo for sure the snow was
the snow was like frozen around me and
like not moving
let me back up you know uh oh no it's
okay
let it do its thing jesse thanks for
streaming oh thanks man thanks for being
here um despite what's going on
uh
my playstation is cooking
the the ps4 pro and i heard it with
these headphones on
let me back up
okay fine i should have let it do its
thing i knew it i'm so impatient i just
wanna
you know do it for the stream
okay good my playstation
calmed down the ps4
there's so many memes about you know
it's a jet engine basically
sometimes it was for uh world war ii
it was very loud
and i changed the thermal paste on it
and everything
coffee danger
aaron yeah i just took one sip
although
one sip is what did it for me last time
what's the best thing i love about this
thanks for your question um
that is a good question i don't think
it's like one thing i think in general
it just
i think it just reminds me of ooh i
think it just reminds me of modern
warfare which i love so
um you know because it's the same engine
and you can highly customize your gun so
it feels familiar i guess that's what i
love most about it
um there's like new maps
but old guns you know it's kind of a mix
of new and old
um
but i am enjoying it i just wish i could
show it to you guys there we go there we
go come on
[Music]
yeah aaron in the chat agrees he loves
the gun customization i wish i could um
i wish all of that was unlocked because
we can make some goofy guns but we're
gonna have to
james get checked for covid man i don't
know
i am responsibly staying at home most of
the time none of that
do i sound ill i might sound ill
the thing is i guess i generally don't
talk out loud this much
come on game
one more come on
for the stream
so bad
dude
why do i know about thermal paste but
not what ping is that's a good question
um
you know on console it's funny by the
way um
on con i've played console like my whole
life
and they have basic you know latency and
ping settings um
i just never i don't know i never picked
up on it it's never been you know when
you're on pc it's always in your face
i just never really i
don't know bottom line i don't know yeah
but i saw a youtube video on how to
change my thermal pace so i did it maybe
i should watch a youtube video on
ping and server latency
servers are just down right now says
jesse you know what i think you know
what folks
yeah this is
this is going to keep happening look at
that they're kicking us out that's okay
let them fix it
meanwhile i'll swap over back boom
appreciate you guys being here sorry
that it ended this way but 90 minutes we
got through 90 minutes um so i hope you
enjoyed
and remember here let me do the update
before i leave
if you're on playstation you can play
all weekend
from the 16th through the 20th just go
you don't need a code you don't need a
pre-order you're good open beta
if you're on xbox you need a code or you
need to pre-order the game to get into
the beta
until
september 18th so september 18th
everyone open access open beta cross
play everything good
uh but that'll do it for me today you
guys thanks for being here thanks for
tuning in i hope you get a chance to try
the beta
and i hope it doesn't break down on you
like this i'll see you next time